Sam is a mythical and ancient deity
whose Origins may go back as far as 500
BCE when the early s celebrations took
place in Celtic Ireland to celebrate the
end of the harvest season and the
beginning of the darker half of the Year
during the Gathering of the Harvest
neighboring hillsides were illuminated
with great bonfires which families would
use to light torches and ignite their
own he Fires at home which some sources
believe were to continue burning until
the Harvest collection was complete
their fires were said to keep away evil
spirits which was important because this
festival called for ancient burial
mounds to be open it was believed that
these Mounds were portals to the other
world a realm believed to contain Celtic
deities and spirits of the Dead on sin
the veil between the living and the dead
would be at its thinnest allowing them
to cross into the world of the living
with spirits and gods roaming free for
an evening a tradition was put in place
to appease them with offerings of food
and drinks in exchange for the survival
of livestock over the coming winter they
also built altars to honor their dead
ancestors composed of elements from the
natural world like colorful leaves
burning candles and symbols to
commemorate the de they also used crops
that were abundant in the fall such as
apples and pumpkins to symbolize the
Harvest and at some point even Place
skulls skeletons and images of deceased
family members to symbolize and honor
the dead in Celtic folklore a shei was a
fairy or flying Supernatural entity but
these are a far cry from the pixie-like
depiction of fairies often seen today
they were seen as troublemaking Spirits
with some of the most popular examples
of Irish fairies being leprechauns short
fused mischievous little men banshees
wailing female Spirits with warnings of
death and changelings deformed unwanted
children that other fairies would
sometimes SW with human babies the Irish
word she literally translates to sudden
blast of wind so their fairies are
really more akin to what we now think of
as ghost sin was believed to be the time
when these Spirits could cross over in
particular there were a few fairies
associated with sin like the puka a
shape-shifting goblin that could take
the appearance of animals or humans and
bring either good or bad fortune the
lady Gwyn was an evil headless woman
wearing whites luring Journeymen into
danger the Dolan was a malicious
Headless Horseman foreshadowing imminent
death or Misfortune to protect
themselves from this array of Spirits it
became tradition to dress up as monsters
to scare away the evil entities this
practice was known as guising you know
like disguising in the 1500s those
wearing the costumes known as Mummers
combined their Traditions with another
practice known as soing from the Dark
Ages they would go door too singing
songs for the souls in purgatory in
exchange for soul cakes failure to
participate in s festivities was seen as
taboo and it was believed that those who
did not take part would be punished by
the gods with illness or even death
celebrations began in the evening on
October 31st the midpoint between the
Fall Equinox and the winter Solas as you
may have figured out by now this holiday
eventually changed and morphed with
other cultures over the years and became
known as all Hollows Eve or what we now
know as Halloween alars for the dead
became Halloween decorations heires
became Jackal lanterns muming became
Halloween costumes and soul cakes became
Halloween candy punishment by the gods
became punishment by toilet paper and
guising became trick-or-treating which
brings us back to Sam as Customs fused
and evolved over the years Sam's role
was to uphold the Traditions at their
core even his name goes back to the
ancient Celtic Festival which is spelled
like this and sometimes mispronounced as
Sam Hayne thank you Dr Lumis to learn
how Sam became the everpresent deity
upholding the rules of Halloween set
thousands of years ago stick around to
the end of this
[Music]
video Welcome to Horror history this is
a show where I analyze the timelines and
lives of some of the most feared
characters in the horror genre but
occasionally in Horror history we have
to go back in actual history to
understand a character's Origins however
I have to admit that is only partially
the case today while sa and fairies and
banshees were all actually a part of the
Irish folklore dating back thousands of
years Sam was not actually a part of
that in real life he wasn't even Loosely
based on a character from Irish folklore
while there are an array of deities sin
was not one of them it was just the name
of the festival literally translating to
Summer's end Sam Actually began as a
doodling that writer director Michael
Dory created in class when he was born
the burlap sack over his head is meant
to make him feel like a cross between a
pumpkin and a scarecrow DH wanted the
design to represent the holiday's dual
nature cute and creepy fun and
frightening mischievous yet malevolent
after making hundreds of drawings of the
character he decided he wanted to do
something with it so he spent 9 months
handdrawing the animated short film
season's greetings as a senior thesis at
NYU then the character was featured in
actual greeting cards that he sent to
friends and family and eventually he
sold the cards to a local shop in
Burbank for distribution Sam also found
his way into other animated shorts such
as hellmark cards in 2001 he also began
to experiment with sketching Sam without
the mask at this time after showing the
short film off around the industry he
was advised to write a featurelength
script as a vehicle for the character so
he combined three short stories he'd
written as homework assignments in
college to create the script for
trick-or treat so Sam's association with
the ancient Celtic culture is something
that only exists in universe but in a
way the rise in popularity of trick-or
treat through screenings merchandising
and fan artwork has cemented Sam is a
Halloween icon he's become an unofficial
mascot of the holiday and that was by
Design D explains I realized that while
Christmas has Santa claws Easter had an
egg Ling rabbit and Valentine's Day had
chubby winged children that shot arrows
at your heart Halloween was missing a
mythological mascot I knew the character
must be out there he was just hiding the
image most commonly associated with
Halloween is the Jackal Lantern which is
a practice derived from the Irish folk
tale of Stingy Jack an old drunkard Who
tricked the devil into agreeing to never
take his soul leaving him to Forever
wander the pl Between Heaven and Hell
with only a light inside of a hollowed
out turnip to light his way that turnip
eventually became a potato which
eventually became a pumpkin which
eventually became Jack Skellington Sam
continues the tradition as his uncovered
head seen at the end of trick-or treat
resembles a hollowed out pumpkin skull
and his body is filled with pumpkin guts
while DH has stated that he'll never
reveal Sam's true Origins there is an
extensive history to unpack in the
comics the movie and many short films
that the character has appeared in so to
fully understand the motivations to this
mysterious malevolent munchkin we've you
got to take it all the way back to
Ireland in the mid
[Music]
1600s on October 24th 1640 a man named
Thomas is criticized for showing Mercy
on witches during their execution the
man in charge of the executions
Commander wolfi explains that the
harvest season is ending and the Pagan
witches will soon be at their full power
he sends Thomas to the interrogation
tends to toughen him up where he rescues
a suspected witch named Bridget she
explains that what Thomas's people
perceived as a devil worship ritual was
actually an act to honor the spirits of
the Dead We believe it's the one night
when they're permitted to return so we
light candles and bonfires to guide them
we offer crops as gifts and dress in
gues to protect them and us from the
truly dark Forces that prowl the night
she clarifies that they believe all life
is sacred and uncovers a seed hidden
away under a specific Rock claiming it
contains the last of her people's magic
as days and nights pass Thomas is unable
to see the devil in her eyes and Sam can
be seen observing Thomas's internal
struggle from afar on October 30th
Bridget is tortured by some of the other
soldiers and uses her magic to break
free and grow pumpkin Vines which are
able to shape themselves to unlock her
cell instead of escaping she finds
Thomas who is grown sick and uses her
Vine magic to cure him while
simultaneously giving him a vision of
the slaughtering of her people by the
Christian Soldiers her execution is set
for the next night October 31st sin
Thomas attempts to rescue her but
they're captured by commander wolfi and
as they're being burned at the stake
bridgid sees Sam his eyes glowing in a
clearing and believes that her prayers
have been asked
wolf Rick smashes her magic pumpkin but
the next day a young girl discovers it
collects the seeds and brings them with
her during her eventual Journey to the
new world Thomas and Bridget go on as
spirits and Sam's face can be seen in
the blood moon that supposedly gives
power to their Pagan cult Sam's role in
the story is essentially a protector of
the sa magic that allows the
supernatural to come to life on October
31st Thomas and Bridget are forbidden
lovers whose relationship represents the
cultural diffusion that occurred to
combine the pagan holiday of sin with
the Christian holiday of All Saints Day
to to create Halloween as it is
celebrated in the west today we
literally see their seed go on without
them to the new world where Sam would
continue to watch over it for Autumn
celebrations across many different
cultures the next of which would be in
the Wild Wild
[Music]
West Illinois October 29th 1853 European
settlers have brought their Halloween
Traditions to the Americas and are
actively spreading further West through
the construction of a transcontinental
railro when we first meet our main
character of this story Sarah she's even
reading The Legend of Sleepy Hollow the
tale of a man haunted by a headless
horsemen a direct connection back to the
Celtic fery the Dolan proving that the
Halloween she celebrates has a direct
connection back to irand but they are
not the only ones celebrating the
falling leaves Sarah's father discovers
a Native American tribe blocking his
potential train route Sarah befriends a
native girl named Pani who teaches her
about her tribe Shaman praying to the
corn Maiden as thanks for their
Bountiful Harvest they discuss good and
evil spirits so Pani gives her a small
cornstalk version of Sam even though the
tribe does not know what Halloween is
they still recognize Sam which tells us
that Sam is a deity who watches over all
automnal festivals from a variety of
cultures not just those directly derived
from sa Sarah asks if he's a good spirit
and Pani tells her I would not say that
but the shaman told me he is very old
and very powerful Sarah carries her Sam
doll with her as she tries to convince
her father to leave the natives alone to
no avail in the night she sees the corn
maiden and follows her Shadow back to
the tribe where she's informed that the
maiden was once a human whose touch
brought life to the crop Fields but when
the gold Seekers arrived they feared her
magic and killed her but even when her
blood fell fertile crops arose they
celebrate the Autumn Harvest to honor
the corn maiden and teach children of
the dangers that lurk in the dark hearts
of man Sarah tells of her own Halloween
traditions and they agree to celebrate
together the next morning she even gets
the unexpected blessing from her father
who sends her with candy Sarah crafts
her own saml Lantern to protect them
from the evil spirits but soon discovers
that the candy her father father sent
with her was poison as a covert attack
by her father looking to clear out the
Indian settlement Sam or she knows him
the great Autumn Spirit takes notice
follows her to the Shaman's cauldron and
seemingly grants her the power of the
Corn Maiden giving her the magic ability
to take revenge on her father and his
friends vitriolically growing vines out
of their intestines before appearing in
the fog with Sam at her side and
annihilating her dad she takes Sam's
hand before disappearing back into the
corn with the only evidence left behind
a patch of pumpkins with the settler
shocked faces imprinted upon them in
this story Sam demonstrates how the old
tradition of guising and soing must be
honored even as it takes a different
form on a new continent the deal is to
offer Suites in exchange for culture the
tribe shares their culture with Sarah
and by extension the settlers with the
railroad men violate the deal by
poisoning the candy given in return and
this is not the last time we would see
Sam act on a situation like this but
first Los Angeles October 30th 1955 Jake
Perkins is a private investigator
without any interest in celebrating
Halloween one day a woman hires him to
find her missing sister who may have
been involved with a cult leader known
as the echo parked devil his search
eventually takes him to a movie producer
named te nickach who by the way is named
after the nicker Bacher Hotel in
Hollywood which has housed many stars
over the years anyway when he arrives
and Peaks through the window he sees a
ritualistic costume party with many
monsters gathered around a pumpkin
resembling Sam's head thinking Jake is
the killer they kidnap him but once he
clears his name he finds out that they
were all performing a ritual to honor
their fallen sisters the victims of the
Echo Park devil like the pagans in the
first story they too are just
misunderstood innocent celebrating
nature the spirits and the cycle of life
and death they've been praying for an
avenging Angel to finally defeat the
Echo Park devil and they believe that
that person is none other than Jake
chosen by forces much older and wiser
than either of them that Force appears
to be Sam so Jake relents and searches
an abandoned church where he finds the
missing girl just as he's ambushed by
the devil the chase leads them to the
rooftop where after a tough battle the
devil is thrown off the building and
he's eventually unmasked to reveal the
mayor of the city the one C capitalizing
on all of the fear about the killer in
his reelection campaign as if things
weren't strange enough the missing woman
was revealed to have been dead all along
and she did not even have a sister
implying that it was actually her ghost
who hired Jake onto the case with Sam
seemingly pulling the strings it ends
with Jake now with no choice but to be a
believer in the Supernatural in this one
Sam protects the Halloween tradition in
multiple ways non-participants have long
said to be punished by the gods and
Jake's lack of Halloween spirit is
because he believes that dead is dead
and gone is gone he doesn't believe that
any of it is real he's also taught to
honor the dead throughout the story it
is only after finally visiting his
deceased wife and son in the graveyard
when he realizes where the Echo Park
devil is hiding the last story of the
days of the Dead comic takes place about
50 years before modern day most likely
the mid1 1960s James and Rory are a pair
of troublemaking kids who get caught
vandalizing houses on Halloween night
Rory is the son of the Reverend at the
church as they're being punished they're
all surrounded by a horde of classic
monsters including werewolves witches
vampires and demons while the adults are
scared away James and Rory put their
mask back on allowing them to blend in
with the monsters undetected that is
until the Grim Reaper appears before
them and they wake up under an apple
tree in the midst of an awesome
Halloween party put on by the monsters
and decide to celebrate with them
judging by their hands they seem to be
slowly turning into monsters themselves
and they join the crowd as everyone
gathers around the leader which of
course is sad he throws a handful of
candy Into the Fire causing it to shoot
Skyward and some of the monsters fly up
after it James and Rory spend the night
riding around with the monsters
dispersing candy to kids all over town
ending at the church where their
Community is holding a lock in designed
to prevent them from doing anything fun
on Halloween the monsters break their
way in and the boys join them in
terrorizing the congregation when the
Reverend spots Rory he tells him I
always knew there was something wrong
with you Rory attacks him claiming he'd
rather be like a monster than be like
him but just then the clock strikes
midnight and the Monsters disappear into
the night James urges them to take their
mask off before it's too late but Rory
claims that this is where he belongs and
the Grim Reaper fully turns him into a
monster before taking off and leaving
his best friend behind we then jump
forward to basically the present day
where James has just finished telling
his granddaughter each of these four
Halloween tales and she runs off to
trick- or- treat with her friends only
one of them turns back and it's Samad he
looks up and sees Rory in his monstrous
form flying over the moon before he's
greeted by the Grim Reaper and that's it
we don't find out what happened after
that I think Sam's purpose in this story
is to be the Catalyst for Mischief
according to English historian Ronald
Hutton when imitating malignant Spirits
it was a very short step from guising to
playing pranks sa pranks became common
in Ireland and Scotland leading sa to be
known as Mischief knights in parts of
those countries remember Sam is neither
a good or evil spirit he is simply an
embodiment of all things Halloween and
sin it's also significant that these
pranks came at the expense of the church
because While most Christian churches
have come to accept Halloween some very
religious groups still object to its
celebration also this present timeline
with James and his granddaughter is not
given a specific date it's more or less
modern day along with each of the short
films and of course the movie which all
seem like they could be set in the 2000s
a time when cell phones and rotary
phones still coexisted the movie does
feature a werewolf transformation so if
we're going by real world calendars the
nearest full moon on Halloween would
have been in October 2001 however the
movie also features a flashback allowing
us to jump back in time and catch Sam in
a period by
[Music]
gone 30 years before the events of
trick-or treat so most likely sometime
in the 1970s a school bus carrying eight
troubled Disturbed kids from Happy
Shepherd Academy went off its usual
route on Halloween and passed a pumpkin
patch where Sam can be seen crowing at a
dead crow with a stick the bus stopped
before the quarry's edge the driver had
been hired by the children's exhausted
parents to dispose of them but when he
got up to check on their chains one of
the students got free and sent the bus
barreling off the cliff based on the
ancient legends of the spirits of the
Dead roaming free on Halloween Sam did
not necessar necessarily have to
intervene in order for these kids ghosts
to haunt the area every October 31st in
this instance Sam is just a bystander
with an interest in all things morbid
but his next appearance would be less
passive in season's greeting Sam appears
as a trick-or-treater and a man follows
him into an alley and tries to beat him
up but Sam destroys him and Carries him
away in his sack before revealing his
true Supernatural nature obviously the
lesson here is that you don't [__] with
Sam and it's important to keep context
in mind too this was the first thing he
ever appeared in so viewers would have
assumed that he was just a kid in a
Halloween costume until the end to a
bystander Sam appears to just be a kid
in a strange costume in fact director
Mike dhy insisted on it being an actual
child in the costume to ensure that the
body language would be authentic which
ties into the desire to make Sam
represent both the fun side of Halloween
and the scary side Charlie Corgan was a
portly child of 180 lbs according to the
book he typically spent Halloween
terrorizing the mites who took the time
to dress up stealing their candy and
amassing a horde as the night went on
given this Arrangement he didn't have
much need to dress up why bother if you
could just take all the candy you wanted
well maybe one reason is disguising
yourself from getting caught which is
what happens when his principal Steven
Wilkins sees him in the act of taking
more than one piece Wilkins gets the
boy's guard down by offering him more
candy which makes Charlie violently ill
this candy has been laced with hydrop
Floric acid causing Charlie to
projectile vomit a reference to one of
Mike dh's favorite horror movies The
Exorcist after lugging Charlie's massive
body inside three other students come
trick-or-treating at principal Wilkins
door asking to have one of his Jacko
lanterns which he allows them to get
them to leave him alone will'll come
back to them but as they exit he notices
a fourth figure it's Sam who says
nothing as he hastily takes his candy
Wilkins has passed this test there's no
Halloween rule about kidnapping an obese
boy I guess as Sam walks away pay
attention to his
bag it sounds like there's a live cat in
his sack a possible reference to the
original old sketches of Sam Wilkins
buries Charlie in the backyard drawing
annoyance from his nextdoor neighbor Mr
C but not before decapitating him and
using the head as a Jackal lantern that
he carves with his son in the basement
later that night since there's no rule
about what you can use as a template for
your Jackal Lantern remember the
original Jack lanterns were made from
turnips and potatoes this also doesn't
get him in any trouble with Sam however
he would run into other issues later
that night he puts on a vampire costume
for his date that evening who he ends up
making out with in an alley next to the
Halloween parade though his fangs are
fake his bite is real and he draws blood
from the girl whose pleas are ignored
because everyone assumes that it's
costume blood jumping back to the
beginning of the night Lori her sister
and their friends are a group of girls
visiting Warren Valley Ohio for their
yearly Halloween boy hunt and when I say
hunt I mean that literally because
although we don't know it yet these
girls have lycanthropy they're
werewolves I don't know why we drove out
here when there are perfectly good guys
in the city fresh meat they choose a
different city for their ritual each
year Temple was 2 years ago I remember
because you beautiful doing guy in the
back of this pick up I ate some bad
Mexican and it was a je notice how she
didn't say Mexican food the girls each
go as fairy tale characters with Lori
dressed up his Red Riding Hood they set
out to find dates for the party that
they're going to and the girls try to
give her advice about losing her
virginity she goes off on her own for a
while to try to meet someone but
eventually finds that someone has a
Sinister eye on her it's Steven Wilkins
again still dressed in the same vampire
attire from earlier in the evening he
follows her through the woods later that
night sneaks up behind her and grabs her
my
my what big eyes you have only Lori puts
a Twist on the classic t in the original
Red Riding Hood Fable a wolf disguises
himself as Red Riding Hood's grandmother
and tries to eat her but in this case
Red Riding Hood herself is the wolf and
the Predator she tosses Wilkins into the
party wrapped in her cloak then emerges
from the woods in a new costume after
explaining what happens to her sister
she informs Wilkins that it's her first
time and begins her transformation into
wolf as she tears him apart with her
teeth Sam watches this ritual intensely
it's also significant that that Wilkins
goes out as a vampire because vampires
and werewolves are known to be Rivals it
seems to stem from the old Universal
monster versus movies and maybe the fact
that vampires avoid the sun while
werewolves lose control at a full moon
the popcorn Affair between these two
Supernatural races doesn't seem to have
any ties to the ancient traditions of
sin but it is possible that this is a
newer tradition that Sam seems to be
embracing the transformation itself was
shot to stand out from traditional
werewolf transformation scenes in movies
in Tales of Mayhem mystery and Mischief
collaborator Brian Singer explained how
DH wanted it to look like a sensual
experience rather than an excruciating
hatching process the werewolves
transform in a kind of dance of the
seven veils where they strip down to
their true forms there's also a great
emphasis on the fact that Lori is a
virgin which turns out to be a word that
they're using connotatively they're
referring to her first time devouring a
victim but the allegory for sex is
obviously still there if my thesis that
Sam is meant to embody Halloween and its
Traditions is correct then I see no
reason that that couldn't include more
recent Traditions like the one where
many young women use their costumes as a
means to draw romantic attention to
themselves in recent decades the holiday
has taken a page from horror movies to
become something both sexy and scary but
when you're a kid hopefully the focus on
Halloween is more about fear and
Mischief so let's go back to the
beginning of the night once more after
collecting a carved pumpkin from Prince
M Wilkins house 13-year-old chip Macy
and Sarah hit up Mrs Henderson's house
looking for another here we literally
see how Halloween is celebrated
differently as you get older the three
are joined by Shader who has collected
an additional three Jackal lanterns then
they come across the jackpot of all
Jackal lanterns in the front yard of
Ronda who they refer to as an idiot
savan someone with high aptitude in one
subject but reduced intellectual or
social functioning they all head out to
the Quarry where Rhonda demonstrates her
extensive knowledge of sa to chit upon
arriving Macy says that they're going to
pay their respects to the dead and tells
the story of the crash school busz each
of the eight jackolanterns they've
collected represents one of the Lost
Souls from the school we're going to
leave them by the side of the lake as an
offering to those who died the mining
elevator used to descend into the Quarry
Can Only Hold three at a time so so
Ronda and Chip have to wait for the
second trip they hear blood curdling
screams from their classmates below and
when they reach the bottom chip acts as
if he's too scared to go on leading
Rhonda to venture forward and look for
the others in the dark all on her
[Music]
own Rhonda roves through the thick fog
in search of her lost classmates and she
comes across the deserted school bus
with no sign of the others in the
vicinity she's suddenly grabbed by what
appears to be a pair of zombies she runs
for it and finds chip lying on the
ground with another zombie standing over
him intestines dangling from its mouth
they all give Chase and in a moment of
panic Rhonda slips and hits her head on
a rock she's knocked out and when she
awakes in tears she learns that it had
all been a cruel prank orchestrated by
Macy as they get ready to leave Macy
kicks the last nearby Jack Lantern into
the lake extinguishing their final means
of protection against the spirits they
are surrounded by ghostly voices and
before long see the ghastly silhouettes
of the dead school children surrounding
them as they try to escape Sarah is
pulled away into the abyss and Chip Macy
and Trader continue on to the elevator
where they find Ronda locked behind the
gate with the only remaining Jack
Lantern but with her sympathy towards
her spiteful classmates long since
expired presses the button and returns
to safety without them as their final
screams emanate from the Quarry below
Rhonda sees Sam hiding in a pipe and
they have a moment of eye contact or in
her case I guess sack contact that
sounds kind of wrong but each of them
continues on on their way the book
specifically describes this interaction
from Sam as a notd of approval something
I found interesting was that Rhonda is
wearing a witch costume throughout the
story sin was first observed by pagans
in Ireland and paganism has long been
tied to Witchcraft jumping back to the
middle of the evening old man C is the
older version of the bus driver from
Happy Shephard Academy and the legend of
the Quarry Crash from 30 years ago he's
now a grumpy dude living in a dark house
with his dog scaring away
trick-or-treaters and stealing their
dropped candy DH describes him in the
book as a scrooge esque man tormented
for not celebrating Halloween strict
Customs I think an argument should be
made that he's actually celebrating in
his own way although he has no
decorations there's still a spooky
Ambiance and he's clearly feared by the
kids in the neighborhood he doesn't
dress up but he does give his dog a
costume and he does put his own twist on
the exchange for Halloween candy the
visual design of the character is
actually based on John Carpenter the
director of the movie Halloween who has
not been shy about the fact that he
doesn't really care what other
filmmakers do with the Michael Myers
character because he's collecting a
paycheck no matter what because of this
attitude he is paid a visit by the
Halloween spirit Sam first he hears his
dog barking at someone on the front
porch and comes out to find that it's
now covered with over 30 Jacko lanterns
he comes back in to see the doggy door
to the backyard swinging and his dog
barking at something up the stairs as he
turns on the lights Sam can briefly be
seen running across the landing he
follows the sound to his bedroom where
he finds an animatronic skeleton hand
under his sheets and a jack Lantern
resembling Sam in the corner suddenly
Goes Up in Flames and illuminates text
painted on the wall in ceiling in red
the spelling trigger treat give me
something good to eat as he's taking
this all in Sam reaches out from under
the bed to cut his calf Gage Creed style
he looks on in surprise in horror as Sam
reveals himself and tilts his head like
Michael Myers once Sam has peeled his
candy wrapper back to reveal a razor
blade a reference to an old urban legend
about evil neighbors putting razors
inside of the Halloween candy they hand
out C shoots at him but misses blowing
up the Jack Lantern instead another
Halloween s Sam disappears and it's not
entirely clear if he's more of a
ghostlike creature or if he just Dove
out of sight C trips on some loose candy
and falls down the stairs hurting his
hands on the broken glass now at the
bottom as his now tender hands
frantically try to unlock the front door
Sam sneaks up crawling along the ceiling
behind him and ambushes him from above
the wall crawling technique is something
we've dealt with a lot in Horror history
when discussing various demons from The
Conjuring moust to insidious' red-faced
demon to hereditary payment this could
suggest that Sam is demonic though I
don't think he's ever explicitly
referred to as such and as I discussed
most monsters associated with s are
Celtic fairies after a struggle Sam is
thrown into a mirror and C tries to get
the attention of his neighbor Mr Wilkins
for help however he's tackled and choked
so he pulls a move out of Lorie Strode
from Halloween's Playbook by reaching up
to remove the mask of his attacker
what's revealed underneath is a Sinister
looking skull resembling a pumpkin head
with indentations around the eyes and
mouth to better resemble a jackolanter
Sam screeches in his face but C manages
to throw him off so he bounces back to
Feast on the old man's leg however C
also gets a hold of his gun and blasts
SL into the air across the room pumpkin
guts splattering out on impact no amount
of shots however are enough to keep him
down and prevent his severed hand from
stabbing K in the foot like something
out of the Evil Dead 2 when Sam's loose
hand finds the rest of his body he
regenerates puts back on his burlap mask
and grabs a new piece of candy from his
bag a huge lollipop which he bites into
to create a sharp point on the top he
winds up to strike cre with it but when
he goes for the kill his Tomahawk swing
lands in the chocolate bar that cre had
recovered from one of his fleeing
trick-or-treaters by accidentally giving
this chocolate bar to Sam he completes
the trick-or-treating transaction
clearly having chosen treat and the
ancient tradition is complete so Sam is
satisfied and munches down on his candy
like a child as he walks away he looks
back at C as if to say you got lucky
this time and don't let me find you
breaking the rules again and he seems to
have the ability to open and close the
door without touching it upon his exit
adding to his mysterious set of
supernatural abilities when cre answers
the door for trick-or-treaters later
that night he's wearing bandages from
his counter which double as a mummy
costume and he's sure to be generous
with his candy offerings cuz he can see
Sam standing just beyond his yard making
sure that he celebrating the holiday the
right way but Sam's night is not over
and he turns his attention to another
character who's going to violate the
rules of Halloween married couple Emma
and Henry returned from a night of
Halloween festivities and Emma is eager
to take down the decorations because her
mother is visiting the next day against
her husband's warning she extinguishes
the jack' lantern before midnight why
ancient tradition
Henry it's Halloween not H as she
commits this sin Sam watches from across
the street and to make matters worse she
begins taking down the display when
Henry goes inside and utters the
forbidden words I hate Halloween Sam
hides in the box that she's storing
everything in and when she tosses in a
white sheet he explodes on her drawing
screams as he traps her within the sheet
and slices her throat with his
especially sharp Halloween lollipop this
scene terrifies a trio of
trick-or-treaters and he drags her back
into the yard just as he had dragged the
man in the original Shore to see
season's greetings Emma is dismembered
and she becomes the scariest part of the
yard display that she tried to destroy
when Henry comes looking for her he
discovers her head affixed to a post
with Sam's signature lollipop jammed
into her mouth Emma's fate comes as no
surprise not only did she disrespect the
holiday but her extinguishing of the
Jackal Lantern breaks an ancient s
tradition which would have allowed the
spirits and monsters to come out and
harm her which turns out to be exactly
what happened Perhaps it is principal
Wilkins who said it best all these
Traditions Jack
lanterns putting on costumes handing out
treats they were started to protect us
but
nowadays no one really cares but Sam's
holiday traditions surprisingly are not
limited to just one day a
[Music]
year it's presumably a different
Halloween when a young child attempts to
craft himself a Franken steinan friend
using human body parts candy corn and
chocolate syrup Sam lends a helping hand
by supplying the kid with an abnormal
brain which is the last ingredient
before electricity that is to bring this
monstrosity to life it appears he also
takes part in some trick-or-treating of
his own during the day this is from one
of 10 ads for the trick-or treat
marathon in 2012 there are another four
of these that take place on Halloween
each one highlighting one Halloween rule
using this girl they include wear a
costume which doesn't directly feature
Sam but is probably the aftermath of one
of his attacks always Pass Out treats
self-explanatory never blow out a Jacko
Lantern where Sam is presumably the one
dragging this Vandal off screen and
always check your candy where Sam can
actually be seen hiding in the
reflection of this mirror Mike dor is
also known for making the Christmas
horror movie crus which focuses on
strict Alpine traditions and legends so
obviously he knows a thing or two about
other holidays and their Origins and
Customs the rest of the shorts take
place on other holidays and Milestones
throughout the year leading up to
Halloween the day after shows the mess
left behind on the morning of November
1st ending with a pumpkin seed magically
planting itself in the soil which ties
into the idea of a cycle of life and
death that was part of the reason for
the beginning of the S celebration in
the first place it also retroactively
connects nicely with seed the first
trick-or treat comic chronologically
snowman takes place in what I'm assuming
is December based on the Christmas music
where a bundled up Sam helps a little
girl bury her dad alive inside of a
snowman it's not clear if this man broke
some kind of Christmas tradition or if
Sam is still just getting back at people
for the sins that they committed on
Halloween but what is clear is he's
probably not the first one to suffer
this FAS Easter candy features Sam in a
pair of bunny ears seemingly
orchestrating a series of horrific
events at this family's Easter brunch or
maybe just spectating Father's Day is
the wholesome celebration of fatherhood
to the best dad best dad in the
world this skitso middle-aged man sets
up this whole scenario where he has a
family that cares about him using a
series of mannequins on strands Sam the
nice guy that he is offers a shrunken
head stitched like a baseball and the
two play catch finally the last short of
the calendar year before coming back
around to Halloween is called back to
school which shows Sam packing up
various things like his razor blade
candy bar from the old Mr cre segment of
trick-or treat the shrunken head
baseball and glove from Father's Day and
his signature lollipop into a Dead Man's
Bones themed lunchbox which he puts in
his burlap sack and wears it like a
backpack at the bus stop although he
seems friendly to them at first they
eventually end up piled inside of his
bag just like the man that tried to
cross him all the way back in the first
short he ever appeared in seasons's
greetings we don't know what these kids'
transgressions were though each of these
shorts sered to tide us over throughout
the rest of the year until Halloween but
in a way they serve a similar purpose
for trick-or-treat fans Tiding them over
until trick-or-treats can finally get a
sequel the future of Sam is uncertain
but in an interview at Beyond Fest in
2022 Michael DH revealed this I am going
to ask a question that I'm sure you're
all wondering a
sequel I'm very excited about the
possibility uh legendary is very excited
about the
possibility uh it is currently in active
development
uh that does not mean greenlet is an
active
development uh very active uh and I hope
that we'll be able to uh share some more
news about that uh soon if and when that
day comes you can be sure I'll updating
this video with my complete analysis of
Sam so if you love Halloween and love
horror make sure you subscribe to cz's
world for new Horrors every week ring
the death bell for all notifications and
I will see you in the next one assuming
we both
survive